welcome everyone thank you for joining
us at the tissue based research
workflows virtual event
our first presentation for today is
tissue processing a Cornerstone to
Quality Downstream testing presented by
Robin fitzl my name is Serena and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is Interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
during the presentation
to ask a question click on the Q a box
located at the bottom of your screen
type your questions and hit submit
the speaker will answer your questions
following the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the Q a box
to let us know they are experiencing a
problem
please join me by welcoming Robin for
complete biography on our speaker visit
the biography tab on the left Robin over
to you
thank you for joining this like a
symposium on tissue processing embedding
and microdomy the Cornerstone equality
Downstream testing
in this presentation we will cover the
following objectives
pre-analytics steps to ensure molecular
integrity
fixation steps that are required to
ensure morphological and biomarkers
integrity
Pro section which involves prepping and
sampling for good processing
and tissue processing reconsidering
loading and leaving
will cover embedding tips to make
sectioning easier and micronomy
techniques to ensure that you have
beautiful sections
at the end we will have a short period
of time for questions and answers
first of all let's look at the workflow
overview that's involved with tissue
processing
first step is arterial or vascular
ligation
collection then transport reception
prepping processing sectioning
formal and fixed paraffin embedded
sections and molecular methods
I have taken a few of these items and
color coded them to break them into
sections that we can talk about more in
detail
on this slide we will discuss in detail
free analytics involving warm and cold
ischemia
warm and cold ischemy are more
accurately applied to transplant
specimens but for this presentation
relates to the time of ligation to
collection as warm ischemia
and cold ischemia defined in this
presentation as the time from collection
to fixative
when we talk about warm ischemia the
factor that impacts the tissue quality
are several items the most important in
the warm ischemia field is the time to
fixation
you'll see below that that it is
requested that tissue be placed in
fixation and within a 20-minute window
the quicker the better because as stress
response sponsors are initiated almost
immediately after the tissue is deprived
of its blood supply
if you need to keeping tissues near four
degrees Celsius prior to fixation will
slow down some of these processes
induced by oxygen and nutrient
deprivation
prior to fixation tissues should be
maintained in a neutral isotonic
solution with physiologic calcium and
magnesium concentrations to avoid
unnecessary disruption of adhesion
systems and activation of signaling
Cascades so an example of that would be
PBS plus the calcium and magnesium
the other factors that impact tissue
quality include temperature of the
fixative type of fixative volume total
time in the fixative and the size of the
tissue sample and as I mentioned before
we've already touched on the time to
fixation and the temperature let's move
on
to the next slide talk about the type of
fixative
so we've already talked about the time
we need to get the specimen to fixation
and maybe even a temperature we need to
keep it at let's talk a little bit about
the type of fixation most common in the
laboratory is neutral bloodford formalin
and or for formaldehyde there is a lot
of discussion around these two items and
what is one better over the other but a
lot of the literature indicates and
websites indicate that they're basically
the same the only caveat is is I did see
that some commercial options with uh mbf
um is that they might contain a small
amount of methanol which might impact
some of the testing
when it comes to the volume of fixation
needed usually the general rule is 10 to
20 times the size of your tissue that
can be quite a challenge for large
organs
but for most of what's seen in life
science Arena a small container four
ounce eight ounce sixteen is usually uh
doable
with that being said it is important
that if you are removing whole organs
that you do want to prep those organs so
that the fixative and the subsequent
reagents you're going to see in tissue
processing have access to not only the
exterior but the interior especially
items such as kidneys lungs and heart
for those tissues that are
whole or especially if we're going to be
processing uh Rat brain perfusion is
ideal also for cardiac samples too
so after you've prepped your specimen
whether it's bisecting the kidney or
even piercing the serosa of some organs
such as kidney uh uteri maybe even
Livery even those organs that maybe have
a pseudoserosa such as prostate it would
definitely want to make some type of
incision so the fixative can get access
if it's a whole organ
after that for small specimens that have
been sectioned you want 12 to 18 hours
for small biopsies 24 to 72 hours for
standard tissue it is a critical because
formalin although it penetrates rapidly
it fixes very slowly and the whole goal
especially when we talk about molecular
methods is that RNA is uh degrades very
quickly and as soon as the formula can
get to that tissue and make those
methylene Bridges the better to preserve
you will see for molecular testing and
especially for IHC
when we're prepping those uh samples to
be processed in our tissue processor it
is important that we realize that we
have to cut sections that will fit into
the cassettes for adequate processing we
usually suggest sections less than five
millimeters thick or usually in the
Laboratories I'm used to working in we
asked residents or PAs to cut tissues
thinner than a nickel and the size of a
postage stamp
that is because tissue cassettes are
limited in their size by three
centimeters by two and a half usually
unless you're using Mega cassettes
you want to allow for five millimeters
of space around each side of that tissue
sample it's also very critical that you
select the right cassette usually for
routine processing you'll see the
cassette at the top is most commonly
used but for smaller samples especially
for
vessels small biopsies small skin
sections that cassettes down below with
smaller pores are usually idea so that
this sample is not lost
why does it matter when we're cutting
our samples to be processed in those
tissue cassettes as you can see here
from this section in the cassette
automatically you can see that it fits
very tightly at the top and the bottom
not allowing maybe for the fluids to be
able to agitate through
if this tissue is too thick you're going
to see that the interior of the specimen
as you cut into it on paraffin is not
going to suction as well or maybe under
processed
also two of the section is too large it
may not fit on the glass slide when you
cut your sections
those other items here too that you can
run into when the section is not thinner
than a nickel or the size of a postage
stamp or even not even placed in the
correct cassette
so at this point we are ready to begin
our tissue processing
processing of tissue
consists of three basic steps moving
through alcohol to remove your free
water
moving through xylene to remove the
alcohols and get ready for paraffin and
then the paraffin step which certainly
removes the remainder of any xylene
that's residual
and then you're ready for embedding
so after the specimen is loaded into the
processor sometimes it will go through
another step of formal infection but the
major first step is to remove the free
water not bound water and usually we'll
see two to three graded alcohols and
then usually three absolutes the this is
a gradual removal of the free water
where you it's a delicate balance of
removing a free water but not over
dehydrating the tissue
the next step of course is xylene that
replaces removes the alcohol and usually
traditionally we see in Laboratories
three xylene stations it is advised that
you have a small amount of heat on the
last station before paraffin so that
there's a nice transmission
of one reagent to the next being that
paraffin is a solid at room temperature
the last step in processing of course is
then displacing that xylene with
paraffin
I've seen a lot of literature and I'm
seeing in life science Laboratories
where temperature is
being taken more into account based on
the testing that's done in the
laboratory
traditionally we had temperature on
every step of tissue processing but it
was a can I say necessary evil to make
sure that tissue was processed because
in the day we would rather have tissue a
little over processed than under process
for sectioning h e and IHC was more
forgiving for most of that but as we
move more to a molecular testing in the
histology laboratory it is critical to
pay attention to the temperatures I am
seeing more low temp paraffins also
being used
please remember that it is very common
to see pressure and vacuum used on every
step in a processor which is fine but on
the paraffin step it is strongly
recommended that you only use vacuum
because the PV which is a push and pull
in the retort is actually not it might
be pushing that little bit of xiline
that's residual in the tissue back and
forth instead of actually pulling it out
if there is a small amount left in the
tissue we'll certainly see that at h e
which will give you a hazy
poorly defined morphology
have a little snapshot of the type of uh
protocols that you might normally see
in a laboratory this is very common
you'll see that there's three graded
alcohols just two absolutes the three
xylenes and three parabens which is very
common in the laboratory this slide
doesn't include those uh temperatures or
PV but I did want to point out that it
is becoming more and more common uh
because of the molecular testing to
customize protocols for tissue size
sometimes even for tissue type
especially for fatty specimens if
anybody is using those in their testing
one thing that we have been
traditionally
practicing in the histology laboratory
that is that we would take total time
and just divide everything up among the
steps as you can see but I see that more
and more labs are actually taking more
thought into the times they want to set
where they're heavy on the front end of
using 70 percent event and lighter on
the absolute because they're trying not
to remove that bound water the
processing uh the tissue coming out of
the processors is actually easier to cut
the IHC and some of the molecular
methods are more accurate because they
are taking time to really delve into and
customize the protocols for the tissues
they're using in the testing that they
want to do
[Music]
one item that's sometimes overlooked due
to the busyness of the lab is
maintenance I will tell you there are
many artifacts that you will see on your
h e on your IHC
that will go back to the root cause of
maintenance on the processor I have as
you see here I put that exhausted
reagents made for exhausting reworks
because it will require either
reprocessing of the tissue or taking
another sample because the tissues I
can't recover what damage has been done
it is very difficult to remove residual
xylene once it's in the tissue to get it
out to go back
um usually as another sample has to be
taken
that ends the section when we talk about
collection of samples placing them and
fixative long enough making sure the
sections are good and then processing
them we're going to move on to some
information about embedding
embedding is pretty straightforward
there are some tips and tricks that are
helpful
one thing to be mindful of and I
mentioned this previous is that I see
more life science
people in the laboratory taking
temperature into account especially with
molecular testing low temp paraffin is
usually the option of choice
um there are tools that we're going to
talk about and one little note I made at
the bottom and I will explain this a
little bit later is that this is not a
slow cooker for your tissue
so let's talk about embedding medium
please be sure that we talked about the
type of paraffin that's needed for your
laboratory follow the temperature
recommendations on whatever paraffin you
may purchase please remember that this
is not a slow cooker I have been in
Laboratories where tissue cassettes were
taking off the processor placed on the
embedder and either had intentions of
embedding within an hour or so and had
an account where the cassettes had
actually been in the embedder for a
couple of weeks uh this is a critical
note as not only will your IHC be
compromised especially nuclear markers
p53 Ki 67 uh heard to uh
it's really critical to make sure that
they're embedded within a reasonable
amount of time and not kept on the
embedded also the heat will degrade your
RNA
embedding tools are important as we know
there's a plethora of molds available
whether you would choose metal or
plastic
they create the consistency what they
they need I personally prefer metal as
it seems to uh I've worked in clinical
laboratories it makes it a little
quicker to pop those molds out also to
my tool of choice are forceps that are
curved so that the ends of the forceps
do not create any punctures in the
tissue as I will it'll transfers to the
slide I'm wondering why there are holes
in my tissue but allows you to press
firmly on the tissue without creating
any artificial uh appearance also too is
very popular are tampers they're just
um Square pieces of metal usually
aluminum and with a handle attached
you'll see the slide at the bottom right
that allows you to keep the tissue on an
even plane this is critical especially
if you have more than you know one piece
of tissue in the mold I want to make
sure that everything's on the same plane
when you're getting ready to cut so that
you don't have to sacrifice one portion
of your sample to actually get to
another part of that block
thank you
in embedding the tissue there are so
many ways to embed tissue and everyone
has their favorite methods that work for
them because there's so many different
tissue types so many ways to embed but a
few tips I list here is that you know
making sure that tubular tissues such as
vessels are always embedded on ends so
that you can view the Lumen for samples
that we mentioned earlier before
curettings that have multiple pieces
want to make sure those are kind of
toward the middle and all kept on the
same plane by using that tamper
with long tissue
um diagonals always been great whether
you put your block in horizontally or
vertical diagonally embedded tissue
seems to take the impact off of the
blade when you're going to section and
keeps the compression down
for membranes it's always good if you
can use a
applicator stick and wrap that membrane
around there and then place it in the
middle
and keeps it toward the center and able
to uh keep it in this central location
with skin one thing I found to be
helpful is that a lot of times skin has
a
depending on where it's coming from of
course uh thick dermis or subcutaneous
tissue attached and so we would always
embed those diagonally and I actually
liked putting uh the skin down facing
the blade so that I would I wouldn't be
coming up from the Sub-Q which sometimes
would cause the skin to separate at the
epithelium so that's one trick that
might help with sectioning especially
with skin that can be a little difficult
at times
embedding tips these blocks are great
examples of how you want to keep a three
millimeter border of wax around the
perimeter the only one I can see is at
the nine o'clock position where the
looks like some of that subcutaneous
tissue touches the edge of that mold
this gives you the stability and the
support you need with the tissue when
you're taking those sections always want
to make sure when you're putting uh
finishing up your embedding and putting
those cassettes on top try not to
capture any air bubbles avoid under
filling because the if you can get to
the top of that cassette it gives you
even more support if it's if it is under
filled you risk the chance especially
with tissue that can be dense like a
bone uteri of actually popping off
because it doesn't have that support on
the back side
I've seen scientists sometimes take
blocks and in a you know always in a
hurry but just happen to take a rack of
uh or a tray of of blocks and throw them
in the freezer thinking that that would
certainly help move things along a lot
quicker and when they were pulled out
they uh they were cooled too quickly and
just had a lot of cracks that actually
ended up in the tissue and gives you
that artifact on your slide of cracked
tissue
um it's uh on the opposite side of that
it's not good to let those blocks just
solidify at room temperature you
definitely need your chill plate on or
have an ice tray out that you can use
and of course I've done this being in a
hurry uh we try to get our molds out
quickly so that we go ahead and section
and get done but premature mold popping
certainly sometimes will leave some of
the tissue behind in the mold if it's
not ready
moving on to micronomy
the first thing I'd like to talk about
with my micronomy is the Chuck holder
make sure it's clean and tight
usually they're very simple as you can
see in the image at the top or a little
bit more complex on the bottom right
want to be sure that once you have it
set to a zero plane
want to just set it and forget it
there's nothing worse than sitting down
trying to cut tissue that is inevitably
it's always the case that it is a small
tissue and having the plane change where
you have might have the risk of losing
that tissue when you begin to section so
once it's set at zero on either plane
you just want to set it and forget it
with either Chuck holder you will see at
the bottom when you pull the lever
forward to put your block in there are
two Springs at the bottom and we've
already talked about how we keep the
blocks cold and some people use ice
trays well that brings in an element of
moisture and so that moisture can
collect at the bottom of that little
Groove where the block sets so it's
always important to dry that off at the
end of your cutting session and
lubricate it with a couple of drops of
oil so that you won't have problems down
Road also important is that you'll know
that when you put that block in its
Chuck holder in the corners where the
block is kept firm paraffin can build up
in those corners and actually change
your plane too
there are a ton of different blades out
in histology and there's a lot of
conversation and controversy about which
blades are better
you can use high profile or low profile
and it really just depends what works
for you most holders of Blade assemblies
actually have are equipped now that they
can hold either one
as we discussed with the chalk holder
some of the items we will repeat because
it's important with the blade assembly
as well
everything you see on this blade
assembly to the right you'll see there
are three handles one for the blade one
for the assembly that will move the
blade holder back and forth and then one
for the angle want to make sure that all
of these are kept free of paraffin and
lubricated according to manufacturer
recommendations
you will see on the side of the blade
assembly there's always a setting for
the angle
based on the design of the blade
assembly you will see an angle that
needs to be set anywhere from three to
five I'm sorry three to four degrees
I have seen them go beyond that or under
that based on the design of the blade
assembly
why is that important
because you have to have the right
clearance angle to properly section your
blocks
you can see here on this diagram that if
it's not set correctly you can get a
variety of artifactual cutting whether
it's vibration Venetian blinds are
actually the blade biting into the
tissue and you're losing part of your
sample
some of the tips I offer when people are
cutting on a microtome is to make sure
that the sides of your blocks are clean
that extra piece of paraffin like we
discussed before can get trapped in the
Chuck holder or it can eventually when
you're cutting and not keeping the back
of that blade clean you'll see a
paraffin build up that will keep you
from getting ideal sections because it
won't ribbon properly
let's talk about some of the things you
might see in the laboratory that would
be helpful
foreign
keeping the blocks cold is important you
can see here from the Block and the
ribbon that came off of it if it's not
chilled properly you'll get compression
and even even more so beyond that if you
keep cutting you'll see where the
section is not cutting evenly and you'll
have holes in the section as you can see
in the bottom right hand image
more problems this especially if the
blades aren't changed very often you
will see compression of the tissue as
you can see on the water bath to the
right top right and the section on the
left that came off of that
if the blade or the angle is not correct
here's an example of Venetian blinds
some of the tips too I've suggested is
using a dull straight edge to take off
the sides of your block
because sometimes a fresh sharp edge of
a block will help with the riveting
if you have blocks that consist of
tissue that tends to be on the dryer
side such as Pig scan especially blood
sometimes a a trick is just to dip it in
a little bit of chilled water for a few
seconds put it back on the microtome and
then take sections right off the top
once you get your Ribbon then we're
going to place it on the water bath to
be able to pick it up let's talk a
little bit about that
I know the water bath is boring but it's
critical to the Quality we're looking
for temperature is especially critical
because if it's not hot enough the
section won't be able to flatten out and
lose all those wrinkles then if it's too
high then it can cause the section
actually to break apart and we don't
want that either you can see at the
bottom here the water bath is a little
too warm and the section is starting to
separate under h e you can actually see
that separation
with water baths too I wanted to make
sure I mentioned that if you are doing
uh molecular testing it might uh be
important uh to use Ultra Pure Water
I think it's called depc water
which some of you are probably already
familiar with too if you are doing
molecular testing especially with RNA
it's probably wise to use rnas to clean
everything up around your instrument and
on the water bath so not to contaminate
it
foreign
hack and there's a ton of them out in
the field but I'll bring you this one uh
when it comes to sectioning
if your sections and sometimes this
happens with tissue that's just dense
you just can't seem to get a good ribbon
and every section you take you've
chilled it you've moistened it you've
got your temperature at the right temp
in the water bath and you still just
can't get that ribbon as you can see
this one on the upper left is full of
wrinkles
take a beaker or a glass dish and make
up a really weak solution of absolute
right maybe around 40 to 50 percent
we can't use charge slides on this but
you can pick up the final product with a
charge slide
make your ribbon and then lay those
few sections on that alcohol bath then
take a non-charge slide which are
usually just the basic cheap slides
right pick up that rivet and then gently
place it on your water bath you will be
amazed at how that section will gently
spread out and usually get rid of all
the wrinkles so that it's ready to be
picked up with your charge slide or your
charged I'm sorry or slides that are
designed for IHC
one thing about slides after they are
picked up out of the water bath I think
that some of us don't think about
is
whether we put these right away in the
oven or you know if we're going to leave
them out at room temp because the goal
is whether you do either one depending
on if you're doing molecular
we want to remove all the water that's
behind that section that's on the slide
right
with charge slides it's a little bit
more of a challenge because it's charged
to hold the section but it's also it
also holds a tends to hold water so
every time you pick up that should you
want to make sure that you set it
upright on a paper towel or something
that will cause it to drain well
be careful with charge slides if you
pick up a section and it didn't position
right or if you got a little crease in
it you want to lay it back out with
charge slides you can't double dip in
the water bath it might just need to cut
another section
also too with these slides that are
designed for IHC they are not only
charged but they're also designed that
sometimes they're hydrophilic so it's
tough to try to reposition or pull that
section off you may just have to cut
another section so with the goal being
in mind of just trying to get that uh
water out from behind the section in uh
more conventional settings if you're not
doing molecular sometimes you could
leave slides out overnight and that
would work just as well in a molecular
setting we have to be more cognizant of
RNA degradation
and then for anagenicity when it comes
to IHC also so I've been told that
recommendations are usually a low temp
oven around 60 degrees Celsius for about
anywhere from 40 to 60 minutes you can
see here's a couple of examples of
things you'll see if water is trapped
the upper right hand side there's a
water droplet that got trapped and you
can see it's quite evident once you
stain it with h e on the left the same
uh issue happen with residual water the
morphology in this area too will be hazy
and poorly defined sometimes especially
if they put the slides at a high heat
oven
this is just a repeat of the oven tips
that we don't want it too cold or too
hot just right because although h e is
for the most part for giving you still
will see artifacts if it is too hot or
too cold if the water has not been
removed or actually you boiled what
little bit of water was behind that
section we certainly see it with IHC we
also see like I mentioned before the
loss of cellular detail and no doubt
you'll lose the quality that you want to
see with some of your molecular methods
there has been literature out there
um that talks about a sectioning tissue
for IHC
um not too far in advance as if the
sections are taken and not stored
properly uh even
in clinical settings they tend they used
to do it where it would sit at room
temperature you know for a few days
until they did it and we're seeing that
we even at that short amount of time you
see loss of antigenicity I think
especially in a lab that is doing a lot
of molecular testing that would want
sections that are cut right away there
is a recent article out that talks about
if the sections do need to be cut then
coating them with paraffin will preserve
that RNA and IHC targets
I hope you enjoyed this presentation
we'll now open up four questions and
answers
well thank you so much Robin for that
informative presentation
just a quick reminder to our audience on
how to submit questions simply type them
into the Q a box and click the send
button we will answer as many questions
as we have time for
and the first question is
the first question is why is there such
a short time to preserve the specimen
once it is removed
thank you for that question
I'd also like to include uh if I can
before I answer that I believe that my
contact information was not included
if uh the participants would like to
reach out it is Robin
robin.fitzel f-i-t-z-l at
leicabiosystems.com
to to answer the question that you asked
um if there are those out there in the
field
that are uh measuring uh
phosphor related uh proteins related to
cell signaling in tumor tissue uh once
tissue is procured the phosphoproteins
fluctuate rapidly and so that is why it
is ideal uh to move the tissue into uh
some type of fixative or fast freeze it
uh within that 20 minute window uh it's
related you know if you're doing
um uh individual individualization of
molecular targeted kinase therapies and
so that's why I I maybe should have
added additional information that if
you're not doing those that type of
research that the tissue needs to move
into fixative uh within at least an hour
fantastic and the second question we
have here can you explain some
differences using xylene and xylene
substitutes in the lab sure you bet uh
xylene of course those that are familiar
with it provide uh brings into the
laboratory its own level of Hazards of a
lot of
people have decided to move to a xylene
substitute or even to isopropyl
processing I think the thing that
distinguishes is Eileen's substitutes is
that it is an aliphatic uh so that uh
there's features to it that you it does
it doesn't infiltrate as well as xylene
uh so that we usually uh what we see is
that people extend their protocols in
the clearing by about 20 percent uh also
to I believe According to some
recommendations uh it's suggested that
you you change it more often than you do
with xylene
fantastic and it looks like uh this is
our last question coming in it says why
is it important for sections to be less
than five millimeter at embedding oh
good question
um tissues normally cut anywhere from
four to five microns depending on the
tissue of course with lymphatic tissue
and lymph nodes it's higher cell density
so we usually cut those around three
microns uh on the opposite end of the
spectrum usually it's uh brain tissue is
is cut at higher anywhere from eight to
ten microns it's all about the density
of cell so if you're using light you
want the light to be able to pass
through so you can certainly read it
great and if it's okay with you we do
have a few more coming in absolutely one
of these says how long can you leave
samples in embedding center before loss
of tissue quality
I there's nothing
uh written in stone about that uh
usually and I've I've actually reached
out in the field to see what the
consensus was
and uh most felt like it would be ideal
if it can be in the bedding Center less
than 45 minutes to an hour if you are
concerned about depending on what your
target of research is uh the next
alternative was that it's totally fine
once you take it out of the processor
and it's been infiltrated to leave it on
the counter at room temperature uh that
would certainly ensure that those
targets are protected and then once
you're ready to embed you could just
move those to the embedding Center you
know let the paraffin melt and then you
can begin because you certainly don't
want to in bed
or tissue where the paraffin has
solidified into your mold because you'll
get a separation
great okay we have one coming in from
Alexandra it says how would you handle
fresh tissues without PS I'm sorry PFS
fixation for then betting
um I'm thinking maybe
they're asking the question
that the tissues fresh you're doing
cryotomy maybe you're freezing it
so I'm not sure
exactly I I don't think you can do fresh
tissue and paraffin that I'm aware of
okay
maybe some clarification would help
we can do another question if there's
another one okay great let's see any
okay so any particular tip for cutting
mouse or wrap bones
um considering they're well decalified
angles for cutting or water temperature
suggestions
sure
[Music]
um
certainly uh Kudos so that they are well
decalcified
I think the number one issue we usually
run into is tissues usually not by the
time you get it processed you get all
the way down you're running into uh
difficulties uh certainly if it's long I
would do it at an angle taking that
impact off the blade water temperature
still uh I think I forgot to mention
water temperature in the presentation
that it's either wear from around 39 to
41 Celsius so that you get an ability
for it doesn't to break apart but you're
able to stretch out and the little
alcohol trick might actually help with
those type of specimens
great and it looks like um Alexandra
tried to clarify with the question yeah
the question was how would you handle
fresh tissues and they said that the
fresh tissue for cytosectioning
oh that's what I I wondered yeah
um it's pretty much the same technique
as paraffin if you can do long tissue at
an angle to take the impact off the
blade keep it near the center you
certainly want to have enough uh cryo
media to surround give you a nice border
just like with paraffin because it's all
about supporting that tissue when you're
cutting it so uh and if if it's if it
has a lumen certainly you want to put it
on end if it is a sample where you need
to see multiple layers you want to see
it you want to put it on edge just like
with skin right so I hope that might
help and certainly feel free to email me
if I can be a we can expand on that
well fantastic thank you again Robin for
that very informative presentation thank
you so much
and thank you also to our audience for
joining us today and for all their
interesting questions and again we will
address any questions we didn't have
time for today and those submitted
during our on-demand period via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registry registration this
session webcast will also be available
for on demand after the event
so thank you all and that's it for now
thank you